yesterday 17 house democrats pretended  to be dragged away in handcuffs from a  pro-abortion rally outside the supreme  court which they attended so they could  pretend to defend legal abortion after  the court overruled roe v wade and  returned the issue to the legislature in  reality they were not handcuffed you can  tell because both ilhan omar and aoc  briefly pulled their arms out of the  pretend handcuff pose to make a black  power fist for the cameras for some  reason before they put their hands back  and returned to the charade in the dobbs  case the court said that the issue is  for lawmakers to decide you know like  aoc and the alejan omar if they wanted  to enshrine legal abortion these 17  house democrats could propose a law and  pass it and the supreme court would not  do a damn thing to stop them they don't  do that because they don't have the  votes and they don't have the votes  because this issue is a loser for  democrats so instead they larp